Виглядає небезпечно, а ще - це дуже гучно. Якщо виробляти сталь із використанням екологічно чистої електроенергії,
чи можна таким чином скоротити величезні викиди діоксиду вуглецю у сталеливарній промисловості? На цьому заводі стверджують: так!
На виробництво сталі припадає близько 5% шкідливих для клімату викидів вуглекислого газу у світі. Німецькі металургійні підприємства
цей відсоток разюче скоротили. І ось яким чином. Під час традиційного виробництва сталі у доменній печі - з використанням вугілля -
виділяється у 3-4 рази більше СО2, ніж під час переробки сталі у електродуговій печі.
У традиційному сталеливарстві переплавляють залізну руду і коксівне вугілля. Це відбувається доменній печі. У результаті з’являється чавун.
Далі до чавуну в конвертері додають сталевий брухт і переплавляють на так звану сиру сталь.
Із цієї сталі виробляють, приміром, сталеві балки. Під час спалення кам’яного вугілля на кожну тонну виробленої сталі виділяється
приблизно 2 тонни шкідливого для клімату вуглекислого газу. У так званої "зеленої сталі" баланс СО2 значно кращий.
Сталевий брухт потрапляє до електродугової печі, що живиться струмом з виключно відновлювальних джерел енегрії, як-от вітрогенераторів.
При такому процесі виділяється лише 110 кілограмів вуглекислого газу - на кожну тонну виробленої сталі.
Брухт усіх ґатунків надходить зі сміттєсортувальних підприємств або від торговців металобрухтом, переважно місцевих.
Тобто сталевий брухт - це вже перероблений продукт. І тут його далі перероблять.
Розкладають по брухтових контейнерах за типами сталі.
Далі брухт потрапляє до плавильного цеху. Висота стель у ньому - 40 метрів! Усе тут гігантське.
Ось-ось розпочнеться процес плавки в одній з найбільших дугових печей у світі, що живиться від електрики: 61 тисяча ампер при 110 тисячах вольт напруги
дають дуже високу температуру. Ці метрові графітові електроди створюють у печі температуру 1800 градусів.
Між електродами виникають зварювальні дуги - надзвичайно гучні блискавки. Але про це згодом.
В операційній залі процес контролює старший плавильник Кевін Вільсгаус. Він щойно додав спеціальну суміш до металобрухту.
Біля печі тепер помітно, що вона стала працювати гучніше. Зазвичай має бути трохи спокійніше.
Щоб досконало освоїти цю роботу, Кевіну знадобилося 10 років.
Найнебезпечніше - це коли не відбувається охолодження печі. Адже піч виробляє величезні обсяги енергії,
електрична дуга розжарюється до трьох з половиною тисяч градусів, температура плавки підстрибує до 1700-1800,
і якщо охолодження не працює і піч не охолоджується, вона сама себе розплавить.
Процес плавки завершено.
Начальниця Кевіна відповідає не лише за плавку, а й за виробництво сталі, тобто за сталь, яку тут ріжуть і піддають подальшій обробці.
Тут у нас особлива піч, особлива конструкція печі, яка є не у всіх, і, звісно, захопливо щодня спостерігати,
як ця груба сировина перетворюється на високоякісну продукцію.
Металургійний завод у Віттені під'єднано до високовольтної лінії електропередачі.
Вона забезпечує піч та цілий завод 350 мільйонами кіловат-годин на рік. Ось чому тут так важливо економити струм.
Щодо споживання електроенергії та викидів СО2 ми вже нині досягли дуже низьких показників. Наступний крок, який ми нині робимо, -
пропонуємо "зелену" сталь, тобто виробляємо сталь виключно з використанням "зеленого" струму.
У цьому цеху народжується так звана "зелена" сталь - близько тисячі різних сортів. Приміром, куленепробивна сталь для лімузинів
або сталь для імплантатів у медицині. Приблизно півтори тисячі тонн сталі виготовляється тут за день.
Новий процес плавлення. Кевін Вільсгаус робить останні приготування - для нього це щоразу подія.
Це було великим викликом, коли я розпочав тут працювати. Не кожен зміг би.
Хоча усе виробництво тут побудоване на "зеленому" струмі, коштує екологічно чиста сталь не набагато більше, ніж звичайна сталь, виплавлена на вугіллі.
З такої сталі незабаром можуть виробляти екологічно чисті автомобілі. Це теж знизить викиди вуглекислого газу.